Is there a problem?
So, Scare Pewdiepie starts early today
So me and Marzia decided to go to Little Tokyo
Yeah!
It's a cool place. Let's go
But first, this box arrived
Don't you just love getting a box?
No......
I- I take it all back right away, what the fuck
Someone sent me a gift, I assume it's from you guys
Don't fucking do that
Thank you
Oh my god, I take it all back again
I can't believe it
MARZIA!
HE'S BACK
I was so pissed someone found my address
but you know what
This is the best gift I have ever gotten
Show a clip from last year
Basically last year, I had- we had this cookbook
when I was vlogging and I kept kissing the guy
For no reason
MARZIA
THE BOOK
Marzia: Who's book?
THE BOOK IS BACK!
Marzia: Whatttt? How did you get it?
Someone sent it to us!
Marzia: WHAT?!
Isn't that crazy?
God, I've been waiting a long time to do this
*kisses man passionately*
There we go
What?
Oh my god it's like a pumpkin patch
Oh my god that's huge!
That's so cute!
Oh I feel so down if only something could save me
Oh wait what is this?
Eww I don't wanna
Marzia: Wait what is it?
It's a wellness shot, I don't know what's in it
Marzia: Ewww
Oh it's good
(Totally)
I feel so much better!
Alright, we're at Venice Beach
Where all the Youtube videos are made
All the reaction stuff
All the fake reactions. This is where the real stuff happens
Oh yeah
What do you- OHHH
OHHHHHH
EHHHHH
Ken: That was nasty
Turn you on?
Ken: It's fucking gross
Alright that one- that was pretty cool, that was pretty cool
I'll give him that
Hey Ken, can you do that dance move?
Ken: OH YEAHHH, YEAHHH
Last year I was too weak, but now-
Ken: Wow
I'm ready
AHH I can't, it's too high
Ken: Don't be a pussy
I'm too short
Ken: YEAHH
Ken: Do a back flip!
Ken: Back flip!
BACK FLIPPP
I'M SCARED
AHHHHH
Ken: You did it
(TOTALLY DID)
We're heading back, Scare Pewdiepie starts now
What can you do, what a great day
Today was the best day
Ken: Been outside for 10 minutes
We've been-
This is the vlog guys, 10 minutes outside. YEAH
Alright, bye Marzia
Marzia: Bye Pewds!
Bye Slippy
Man
It's insane how busy I am here
I know we were just by the beach whatever
BUT THAT WAS LIKE 10 MINUTES
But still, these episodes are REALLY FUN like,
this season of Scare Pewdiepie has been fucking awesome
But I mean, let's put it this way
If I could stay home right now and sleep
I would DEFINITELY pick that
That goes for any situation actually
Brad: How many hours?
Brad: 3 hours?
3 hours car ride
Brad: Oh...
Awww
By the end of this car ride
Brad, will have a strike
Brad: I have counter measures today
Oh FUCK
Brad: I fucking told you
Ah SHIT
Brad: But I have some cool counter measures that I have brought
What's that?
It's a 20 Ken
Take off
Brad's shirt
Brad: Come on Ken, take off my shirt
Ken: What do you have going there friend?
Brad: What's up? What's up buddy? Is that 20 worth it?
Ken: Man, here's 20 dollars. Take off your shirt
Brad: Thanks man
HEY! YOU FUCKING
Brad: I'm going to put my counter measure away and we're going to get Felix
Oh you want to spend some money?
You want to spend some money?
HOW MUCH DO YOU WANT?
TAKE IT- TAKE THEM ALL!
HELP ME KEN!
THIS IS SWEDISH STRENGTH
NO! NO!
NOOO!
I'M PAYING YOU
NOOOO! NOOO!
NOOOO! NOOOO!
Ken: YES, OH MY GOD WE MADE IT!
Brad: LOOK AT HIM!
Brad: Now throw it out of the window
Ken: Alright
Ken: What are you doing? Why did you do that?
Ken: He just poured water over my shoes for no reason
Cause I can't fuck with your shirt
Brad: That-
IT'S WATER
KEN: IT'S ANOTHER STRIKE!
IT'S WATER!
It was worth a strike
AHHHH, OHHH
OH MY GOD YOU GOT WATER ON ME!
OH YOU-
We have 3 hours in this fucking car...
Brad: That's stinky. That's stinky.
Brad: That's no fun. No one wants that
This is just the beginning
Ken
You see this?
Ken: DAMN SON
What are you grabbing for?
Ken: His nipples?
He's getting his counter man
He's talking about he is having a counter measure
RIP HIS SHIRT APART. There's holes in it
You want that money?
COME ON
DO IT. I'LL HOLD YOUR MONEY FOR YOU
Brad: You can't, you can't destroy my shirt
HE CAN
DO IT MOTHERFUCKER
I KNOW YOU'RE POOR
What do you got there?
Brad: You freaking asshole
What do you have there? What the fuck is that
GET THE COUNTER MEASURE
BUSTIN IT
GET IT OFF HIM
AHH
AHHH
AHHHHH
Ken: What are you doing?
What a- what an idiot
The fuck are you doing?
I get it. Just keep going
Brad: Let's help him out
We're fine a-
Brad: Get on in here boy
OHHHHHH
Mike, you edited out a stike
You edited out a strike?
That's
3 strikes
4 strikes, 4 strikes
You got one strike, because you got a strike for this footage of the egg
What is this?
That's the egg!
YOU DIRECTLY FUCK WITH MY SHIRT
Micahel: I just had you!
Brad: So then Michael, like ran after me
Michael: Because it doesn't count as a strike
Michael: Then you can't touch me!
Michael: When I can touch you, then you can touch me
If you get an egg on the shirt
Micheal: IT DOESN'T MATTER
Michael: You can have whatever you want on the shirt
The strikes are, tearing us apart
All the strikes is ruining our friendship
This is what we Swedish people do, thug in the- in the high schools
It's hard
OOO
Whose is that?
What are you doing?
What happened to you? What have you become?
Look at you
Look at what you've become
Now I can do it
OHHHHH
Human powered
Swedish
I've never been so proud to wear these colors
CIN-NA-MON-TOAST-KEN
Fancy to see you here
You want to arm wrestle?
YEAH I WANT TO ARM WRESTLE
Well, the winner gets the other person's Youtube channel
(BRING IT)
READY?
Ken: YEAH
3, 2, 1
Ken: COME ON FELIX YOU CAN DO IT
COME ON KEN
YES
Ken: COME ON FELIX
COME ON KEN
YOU CAN DO IT KEN
AHHHHHHH
AH
YES! PEWDIEPIE WINS!
OWWWW
AHHHH
LOOK AT THE IDIOT
AHHHHH
SQUISHED MY FINGER!
MAN EH
Broke your fingers
I broke my-
That's the thumbnail. THAT'S THE THUMBNAIL
THAT'S IT
How do I make it look even broker
AHHH. I broke my fingers
Is that a good thumbnail? Would you click on that?
Fucking weirdo
Clickbait
Check out what next clickbait we're going to do tomrrow
Do I, smell like shit?
Sorry to tell you but
I WONDER WHYY!
Give me a hug
Give me a hug, come on
COME ON. GIVE ME A HUG
No, I'll take a strike
As you can see, I'm covered in shit
And if you want to find out why
You got to watch Scare Pewdiepie
Hope you enjoyed this Birdabo
As always, thanks for leaving a like
I'll see you bros-
In the next episode
Knew it. I told you, it was hidden
In here?
No
That's why it was in a different spot
What do we got?
Heh, that's actually good
Look at the whole collection of dicks
(Not pleased at all)